you acting like we on our way to home
depot
i don't wanna die
welcome back this is gonna be my new
fast and furious night trailer video
it's as big and ridiculous as you would
expect it to be
there's all kinds of easter eggs and
references characters coming back from
old movies
big twists so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
people are telling me that john cena is
apparently in the movie but i can't see
him anywhere in the trailer
are you sure about that everyone post
all your jokes in the comments below i'm
sure there's going to be plenty of those
when the movie actually comes out
i think probably some of my favorite wtf
moments from this trailer
are them actually going to outer space
like they joke at the beginning of the
trailer with the car and the spaceship
that little brian is playing with
is to foreshadow that they're actually
doing the meme like the producers of the
movie vin diesel are like
yeah we saw all your avengers infinity
war thanos jokes and memes about the
fast and furious family
battling in a car race in outer space to
save the universe in the joke's on you
because we're totally doing the space
thing then at the end of the trailer
they pay that off with ludacris and
tyrese just
screaming their heads off as the rocket
car detaches from the shuttle and
activates its rocket boosters
that's built by brian in the tokyo drift
crew that they brought back
even bow wow is back for this movie and
just to give you an idea
context for how long it's been he was
still called lil bow wow when tokyo
drift came out
obviously the biggest twist here is them
bringing han back hashtag justice for
han paid off
don't worry we'll talk about that
because there are all kinds of theories
about how they're explaining han coming
back in this movie
it is crazy as you would think it's
probably some of the least crazy twists
that actually
happened in the movie that's the whole
point of the franchise like you thought
the last movie was crazy hold all our
beers which are coronas notice they all
drink coronas in all these movies
because we're going even crazier in the
sequels
and if you guys didn't see the news
they're actually taking another page
from avengers infinity war and avengers
end game i mean we have vin diesel
coming from the marvel universe this is
like his other big franchise that's
almost as big as the mcu it seems
fast 10 was going to be their last movie
in the franchise they were just going to
cut it at an even 10 movies
it's been going for forever so it makes
sense 10 movies that's pretty solid run
but when they were planning the next
film fast 10 they decided that they
wanted
to be even bigger so they're breaking it
into two parts like avengers infinity
war used to be part one and part two but
then they made part two of andrew's
endgame
so that last movie will technically be
fast 11
they didn't say exactly when that's
coming out because everything got
delayed with the virus but it won't be
called fast11 they'll just call it
something else like the final fate of
the furious
you can post all your theories in the
comments about what you think they're
actually going to call that last one
but they also have a bunch of new
footage of paul walker that they worked
in with his son
jack from the franchise who would be
even older than little brian at this
point technically
dom secret love child with elena don't
worry there's so many twists like i said
twist upon twist upon twist
and we haven't even gotten to dom's
brother john cena yet
it's a little bit like the spaceballs
meme my sister's brother's cousin's
mother's
sister's roommate but there's a line in
the trailer about how
they're a family they always come back
together that's a reference to them
bringing back pretty much
every single person who's ever been in a
fast and furious movie for these last
few ones in the franchise
i'm sure they'll even bring back the
rock and jason statham from the spin-off
movies once he and vin diesel
make nice again and put their beef aside
it is pretty conspicuous that you don't
see the rock amongst all these other
characters they brought
han back from the dead so to speak at
least metaphorically
but they didn't bring the rock for this
movie you notice that they've gone back
to dom's home
from the first fast and furious movie
like this home in california
remember they were living on the dl
because they made hundreds of millions
of dollars from one of their big heists
but then
eventually they decided that they needed
to go home quote unquote
so a lot of what the family did in the
last few films was to clear their names
so that they would be allowed by the
government to actually come back to
california without being arrested on
site
obviously the whole twist here is that
charlize theron's character is still
supposed to be somewhat of the
overarching villain of the series and
she's roped in
jacob john cena dom's brother from the
past that we didn't know about till now
and whatever their evil plan is is what
brings the family back together
to fight them although it does seem like
the only reason why charlize theron's
character brings dom's brother back
is to take him out of the equation like
whatever she's trying to do
he's the only person who could stop her
and bring the family back together
it does seem like dom sacrifices himself
earlier in the movie to save letty and
late believe he's dead for a little
while so you have a lot of action
with letty and the other characters
where dom isn't around
but because of the way they cut the
trailer it's a little confusing because
you see dom
working with a lot of them fighting
against his brother jacob
so either this happens earlier in the
movie and then he rejoins the family
later or this big twist where he
sacrifices himself is one of the
cliffhangers that they end the movie on
and then they bring him back during fast
10. like they actually
do in avengers infinity war thanos snap
where they
seemingly kill the character off then
pull an avengers end game where they
bring them back in the next film
speaking of them borrowing marvel
references and easter eggs they pull a
black widow move where both he and john
cena
steal each other's guns and just pull
them back on each other
i believe the explainer for john cena's
character the way they explain him being
dom's brother is that he's not his
biological
brother like he wasn't born to the same
mother but as a child he was taken in by
dom's family and became like real family
then pretty easy prediction to make as
usually is the case in a lot of these
backstories with secret brothers that
you never heard about till now that
they've been on the outs they had some
sort of falling out when they were
younger and then they just haven't
spoken
until now like he says i've been living
in your shadow my whole life but now i
get to be the big one
then you can kind of tell the way they
foreshadow a lot of the bigger twists
later in the film with some of these
early action scenes
like we have flying cars here as you see
john cena's character
drive his car right off of the cliff
then get caught by the plane
it seems like they're using that action
scene to sort of set up the twist later
in the trailer also with them using the
rocket car
in low orbit i don't know if they
actually take the car into space
but it does seem like they're in low
orbit like hey we're almost in space
then just talking more about han's
character hashtag justice for han it
seems like they're back in tokyo here
like where letty is fighting these other
characters where dom
is not around but it seems like this is
where they bring back han's character
and the tokyo drift characters like okay
we're gonna go to tokyo so that we can
grab these characters and explain how
they come back into the story
early predictions for how they bring
han's character back
one is obviously the idea that he just
faked his death they made it seem like
jason statham killed him
and he went on the dl and became some
sort of special agent character working
for law enforcement or some other agency
remember the whole twist of the
franchise with him bringing his
character back and fast and furious six
is that the events of that movie took
place before the events of tokyo drift
so you have him with gal gadot's
character i'm sure they'll try to bring
her back for one of these final two
movies like fast 10 or fast 11.
then he eventually goes to tokyo for the
events of tokyo drift then obviously at
the end of that film is when he's
seemingly killed by jason statham's
character who then becomes the villain
of the main franchise but then
eventually turns good
working with hobb's character in hobbs
and shaw in the spin-off films
this sort of the arc for a lot of the
villains of the series so i wouldn't be
surprised obviously if they bring dom's
brother john cena's character
into the fam and he becomes a good
character during fast 10 and then
eventually
some other villain some bigger villain
than charlize theron surfaces in fast 11
the final film
and she winds up turning good in that
last film you can almost set your watch
by a lot of these twists like new
villain in the franchise
they're going to be a good character by
the next film or within two films
you can post all your theories in the
comments below like this is han
from tokyo drift it's not some secret
double or some face-off situation
how do they explain him surviving the
events of tokyo drift
but part of the beauty of the franchise
is that a long time ago they just found
out
exactly who their audience was and what
they wanted and they've been delivering
on that
each time which is how this franchise
has earned so much money and why they
have earned so many sequels like we know
exactly what you're here for
we're gonna give it to you and we're
gonna escalate things with the next film
it's gonna get even crazier
so everyone post your favorite wtf twist
from the trailer
in the comments below is it han coming
back is it some of these crazy action
scenes
is it the car in space like yeah this is
a joke but jokes on you
we're doing it but what's gonna happen
is my full marvel falcon and winter
soldier episode 5
video is gonna post next that'll be
friday just like normal there'll be a
bunch of falcon winter soldier finale
videos posting next week
vin diesel has also been teasing
guardians of the galaxy three they're
gonna be showing up during thor 4 love
and thunder we'll be getting a trailer
for that sometime soon as well
while you wait for everything click here
for my brand new falcon winter soldier
episode 5
trailer video and click here for that
thor 4 love and thunder first
look teaser thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
hey guys